-You guys, Action Bronson
has been on this show
a great many times,
and we love Action.
And what we love
most about Action is,
you never know what's
going to happen when he's here
up to and including
you never know if he'll be here.
And I am sorry to say that
tonight, he is not.
And he's welcome back anytime.
But I will say, when you'r
supposed to be on a talk sho
and then you don't show,
[bleep] that's capricious.
[ Laughter ]
But we've got
a fall-back plan, you guys
This is a big deal for us.
I can't believe we got him
You know him not just from doing
cue cards at our show.
He's also been doing cue cards
at "Saturday Night Live"
since 1990.
Please --
Well, just welcome from
backstage -- He was here.
He's always here.
Please welcome Wally Feresten.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God.
[ Both laugh ]
-Hey!
Hey! Steve! Mike!
How you guys doing?
How you doing?
How's everybody doing?
I know everybody.
-Take a seat.
You know everybody.
-Yeah. I kind of had
a rough entrance there.
-Yeah, I was going to say,
seven years in,
we've never had
anybody crash into the door.
-I'm used to coming
in from that way, not --
-Yeah.
Well, it's still just a door
-Yeah. That's a good point
-Yeah, I mean,
if you go through one door
you should be able to
get through most.
You know, actually,
I'm bummed out,
'cause when you came out,
I thought we
should have done that --
You know sometimes when people
hit their first home run,
none of the players clap?
-Applaud. Yeah.
-I should have told the crew
"Don't clap when
Wally comes out."
-That would have been funny.
-Wally, thank you so much
for being here.
Now, a lot of people
think you just hold cue cards.
You actually have a compan
and you do cue cards for
a lot of different shows.
And I want to ask real quick
you had to come up with
a name for company that
encompassed everything it did,
and it had to be a name
that would immediately
make people think, "That guy
obviously knows
what he's doing."
Obviously, you went throug
hundreds of names.
I remember you doing it.
Can you please tell everybod
what you came up with?
-New York City Cue Cards.
[ Laughter ]
What I finished on.
Probably wasn't 100 names.
It was probably the first thin
that came to my mind.
And I was like,
"That's perfect."
-Wait. What about
Cue Cards by Wally?
-Well, that's my other company
-Oh, tell everybody about
Cue Cards by Wally.
-Cue Cards by Wally I starte
during the pandemic,
when I wasn't working.
I was bored and I was
sitting around at home.
And I thought, "If I can't d
cue cards for celebrities,
like yourself and other people
"why don't I do personalized
cue cards for people at home."
Because they can't
go to birthday parties
and they couldn't go to parties.
It's kind of a
perfect time to do it.
-And these are on the iconic
"SNL" cue cards.
-Same cue cards
written all by me,
which I was shocked to think
people would want,
but they did.
And every time I sent one ou
and I looked at it
before I sent it out,
I was like,
"They're really going to b
disappointed, I think,
'cause it's just really marker
on a piece of cardboard."
-Yeah.
-But every time they got it,
they were like,
"This is the greatest thin
I've ever gotten in my life.
And they loved it.
-It's really nice when
someone is willing to admi
that their product is just
marker on a piece of cardboard
-It really is.
-Yeah.
I mean, I think that's one
of the things we love about yo
is your honesty.
The other thing I want to sa
is, you know, this is no jok
that Cue Cards by Wally
is a big deal.
I, in my dressing room,
have my last "SNL" --
I have the cue card from my good
night at "Weekend Update."
And, sort of famously, a lot o
cast members want a cue card
and a lot hosts
take them home with them.
-Yeah, I'll put together
a package, usually, for hosts,
and sometimes, I'll say, "Hey,
do you want some souvenirs?"
So, I just sent -- It's funny.
I sent Carey Mulligan
a package of her cue cards
And then I did
the Elon Musk show.
And I got home,
and there was a note --
a handwritten letter
from Ireland.
I thought it was
from somebody else.
So, it was after the show,
and I was really tired
and I was reading it.
And I still thought it was
from somebody else,
and it was from Carey Mulligan
thanking me for
sending her the cards,
because she was like,
"I felt like it was a dream,
but having these kind of make it
feel like it was reality."
So it was really nice.
-Who was the
Irish person you thought
you were getting a letter from
Halfway through a letter
from Carey Mulligan,
and you're like --
-There was an Irish guy that
connected with me on Faceboo
that said he was
coming to see this show,
and it was the week after
we shut down for the pandemic.
-Gotcha.
-So he couldn't come over.
So, I sent him an Irish --
You made a joke about
Irish people and drinking,
like you normally do.
-Uh-huh.
-And I sent him those cards.
And I thought this was
a thank-you note for that.
-Oh, that's very nice.
Well, there you go.
-That's why I was confused
but then --
-I don't -- That wasn't a joke
That was based on
something in the news.
-Oh, okay. Okay.
-Yeah.
-I mean,
I'm not just going at them
These aren't just, like,
ad hominem attacks
on our friends across the seas
Hey, so, this is --
I want to talk
because I actually do think --
You know, one of the questions
I get asked a lot --
We used to do a Q&A
when we had an audience here
And a thing that people
are genuinely fascinated by is
why does our show use cue card
instead of teleprompter?
-Right.
-Now, the cue-card shows, as I
understand it, are --
They all kind of come from
the "SNL" tree.
-Correct.
-Jimmy uses cue cards.
Conan used cue cards.
-Yep.
-You did him.
We use cue cards.
And I think it is,
that's how we came up.
-Yeah.
-When hosts come on "SNL,"
a lot of times,
it's the first time
they have used cue cards.
-Yeah.
-So what is the first thing --
And I've watched this happen
But explain to people
the first thing you have to do
when a host gets there,
insofar as the cue cards.
-Well, first of all, I ask the
how their eyesight is,
'cause that's
the most important thing -
if they can see alright.
And, so, I'll show them
a normal-sized printing card
and then I'll show them a little
bigger-sized printing card
just so we can
get off on the right --
So, then I ask if
they've ever worked with
cue cards before.
And most of them haven't.
So, it's just a basic talkin
about, you know,
seeing them alright.
And then, you know, Don,
the director of "SNL" --
between me and him,
and then we'll talk to the
about more specific things
about how to play them
and, you know,
where to look at them
and don't memorize anything,
that kind of thing
-And if you had --
And, sometimes,
you have a host who thinks
they're not going to need cards,
and then, over the course of
the week, they --
-Yeah. Like, you know,
Matthew McConaughey.
He was the nicest guy,
but he was like,
"Eh, I'm not going to use
the cue cards."
And I was like, "No problem.
I'll be over here,
you know, if you need me."
And then by like
Friday afternoon, he was like,
"So, where are you going to be
in case I need them?"
And then I was --
"I'll be over there."
And he was like, "Okay,
just in case I need you."
And then, on Saturday,
he was like,
"Alright, where are you
going to be for each sketch?
And he thanked me after
and he apologized.
I go, "You don't need to
apologize."
But he was like, "I didn't
understand how inclusive
the cards were
and how much it changed."
-That's the thing.
The real reason you can't
memorize on the show
is that there's no --
-It changes so much.
-You just changes so much.
-Yeah.
-You had a moment that
I always recall fondly
with Charles Barkley.
That was a
Saturday rehearsal, yeah?
-Correct.
-And do you want to
tell everybody what went down?
-Yeah, so, Chris Kelly,
the stage manager,
came over to me and said,
"Charles wants to play
a practical joke on the cast
and he's going to
pretend to be mad at you.
No one knows about this
but me and you."
He's like,
"Are you good with that?"
And I was like, "Yeah, sure.
Why not?" You know?
So, we went out there
for a sketch,
and right in
the middle of the sketch,
Charles breaks character
and he starts yelling at me.
He's like, "Wally, I can't -
Hold the cards still.
I can't see them."
HE's like -- And he stormed off.
And people were like --
-I fully bought it.
-People were, like, shocked.
Will Forte actually yelled
"Hit him" to Charles.
He told Charles to hit me.
So -- Which I took
umbrage to a little bit.
-Yeah, I mean, of course.
That meant that
he thought it was true,
and he finally thought you
were getting --
-Yeah, he was like,
"Wally is gonna finally get hit,
you know,
get what's coming to him."
So, Charles stopped
halfway off the stage
and then said,
"I'm just busting."
And everybody laughed,
and it was great.
I was beet-red,
even though I knew about it.
I didn't -- You know,
everyone was staring at me
And then I went over to Will
and I was like,
"What the hell, Will?"
He was like,
"Oh, I was just trying to
diffuse the situation."
I don't know.
-I remember it was like,
"What the [bleep] Wally?!"
It was very --
-Yeah.
-I think the part
that I can't believe
all these years later is,
I'm like,
"I can't believe Charles Barkley
was such a good actor."
-Yeah.
-And, by the way,
I didn't yell "Hit him,"
but, at the same time, like,
if he had started hitting you,
I would not have done anything
mostly -- Not because
I don't love you.
He's a big guy.
-Yeah, he's a big guy.
I get it. No, I understand
-And you do sometimes
move the cue cards.
You know it and I know it.
You move the cue cards.
Wally, you know,
and one of the other reasons -
and I want to be sincere
for a second --
that we don't use a teleprompter
is, we have a deep friendship.
You've been holding cards,
and I always say,
like 95% of the words that I
have said on television
over a career that's
almost like 20 years long no
are cards that
you've been holding up.
And I remember that when
I did the Golden Globes,
we had you there just in case,
standing in a tuxedo
next to the teleprompter,
just in case
something went wrong.
-Yeah, I never returned that
tuxedo, by the way.
-You never returned it?
-No, I kept it.
That's okay, right?
-Well, it's very unfair for yo
to say it now,
in front of America.
This is Wally.
You can see him most nights --
most nights on "Late Night."
Thank you so much
for being here.
Action, again, we do hope
you come back soon, as well.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."